Speaker 1: It's great to welcome back
to the program today, Nick mid-July,
who is CEO at Ritholtz Wealth Management
and also founder of Of Dollars and Data,
a data focused personal finance blog to which
I subscribe. Great to have you back on, Nick.
Speaker 4: Nice to see you again, David.
Speaker 1: So, OK, many in my audience
are millennials or they know millennials
or they've heard of millennials at least,
and are probably familiar with some of the
headlines that say millennials dramatically worse
off financially than their parents, than their
grandparents. The millennial generation is just
financially a disaster. Oftentimes, student loans,
combined with stagnant wages are pointing to,
et cetera, et cetera. OK, so that may be true.
I think I want to understand how these things
are being calculated first and foremost.
So maybe let's start there. When those
headlines are written, what are they based on?
Speaker 4: They are based on. So one of the big
stats that people use, they look at the share
of total wealth that every generation owns.
And so the Federal Reserve basically says, OK,
here's one generation they could use years and
ages and years and years boomers, here's Gen X,
here's millennials, et cetera. And they just say,
like, what percentage of the total wealth do they
owned by these estimates? And the percentage that
millennials own right now is smaller than the
percentage that boomers owned at the same age
and smaller than, what, Gen X under the same age?
That only issue with that is the pie has gotten
considerably bigger. Right. So that's that's
something to consider. And then you also have to
look at like, OK, adjust for inflation. You have
to adjust for the number of households there are.
Now, there are, I think, more millennials
and boomers. But at one point, I mean,
you go back five, six years, that wasn't the
case. Boomers are the largest generation. But,
you know, as as that generation dies off, you
know, millennials basically are taking over.
So I think there is some truth to that. There is
truth to the student debt loads. There's truth to
stagnant wages. Those things are happening. But I
think you have to look at a much broader picture.
I think those are they're focusing on a very
small selection of millennials and not the entire
if you look across all millennials, you
kind of aggregate things and look across
the entire generation. I don't think it's
as dire as the media makes it out to be.
Speaker 1: So make of that case. I mean, how can
we how do you defend empirically the idea that
millennials actually aren't aren't so poorly off?
Speaker 4: Yes. So if you look at inflation
adjusted per capita per household, net worth the
same. I'm using the same data source that they
used to say millennials are poor, using the same
data source from the Federal Reserve. You look at
those trends over time, and I would have to say
I could send you a charts and my blog post, but
there's a chart which shows like, OK, here's where
millennials are. Here's where boomers were at the
same age. And like the lines are lining up. It's
like they're on the same trajectory. It's like
people are just getting older and they're we're
gaining more wealth, like even during covid. The
thing I remember, it's like millennials added
one trillion dollars in total wealth to their
generation during covid, which was obviously a
very bad time financially for a lot of people. So
we hear this stuff and like I'm not saying that
there are people struggling. I'm not trying to
debate that. That's definitely true. And I can
in the data, we see that clearly the bottom 10
percent of the millennial generation or
younger households in general are far,
far worse off than any bottom 10 percent, 10
percent of the younger generations previously.
And it's because of debt load. It's because of,
you know, job prospects. There's a lot of reasons
why this is happening, but you can clearly see
it in the data. So if you're looking like, yeah,
there's a lot of people struggling and if you
focus on that segment, you can write stories about
that which are legitimate at the same time to then
paint that subset to the rest of everyone else. I
don't think it's completely fair. And so I'm just
trying to bring a little bit more balance and more
object, more activity to this kind of discussion.
Speaker 1: Now, when we talk about the other thing
is some of these terms, when we talk about wealth,
are we talking about assets or are we talking
about net worth? Because in, for example,
inflation could lead to people having more
assets in a nominal sense. But then if you account
for liabilities, then it's not so. So I think it's
important to understand what we're looking at.
Speaker 4: Yes, we were. And I apologize when
I was talking about those charts and wealth. I'm
talking about net worth assets minus liabilities.
And so like, yes, financial assets are higher,
but debt is also higher, not non. Mortgage debt
is higher for millennials, without a doubt. If you
look at them and they're taking it on earlier than
that Gen X did and which who took it on
even earlier than the boomers did. Right. So
looking at those types of charts, you can see
that like, yes, we are we have more debt than
than any other generation. But the same time we
do have a little bit more financial assets. So
it kind of evens out on on aggregate. But I
remember aggregate isn't what people feel.
People feel their personal situation. Sure. And
just brush it away. But I don't think it's as much
of a crisis as the media portrays it. That's
that's I think where I'm kind of getting at.
Speaker 1: Let's pick one kind of sub issue
within all this that sometimes talked about, like,
for example, home ownership. And that's another
one where you will often see millennials are have
a lower homeownership rate than prior generations.
And then there will be people who say, well, yeah,
that's because the cost of living has gotten
so. Significantly out of sync with wages,
and then you add to that the college debt, and
then you also add to that that people are just
getting married later on. And so there may be sort
of cultural reasons. How how about an issue like
that? How should we be thinking about the real
significance of homeownership for millennials?
Speaker 4: Yeah. So I think you brought up a
lot of the key issues. There are people getting
married later. That's a cultural reason. And
usually when home ownership would happen, like,
for example, I'm thirty one and single right now,
if I were to buy, I could buy a house. But then if
I end up getting married in the next couple of
years or something, I'm going to need a bigger
house. So I would just pay the transaction costs
to do that. So I know I'm not going to be buying
any time soon until that part of my lifestyle is
more cemented. That's the cultural reasons are
true in terms of you actually look at rent rent
over income levels. Those levels haven't changed
that much. You look at it after tax income or
divided by rent. You can look at that ratio.
Those ratios are kind of flat. And so I did look
at that in some way. So rent is not necessarily
all that much higher. So I wouldn't say that,
like, OK, wages were stagnant. If you look at
this analysis like five years ago, this is very
true. But since twenty, fourteen, twenty, fifteen,
things have kind of boomed and like incomes
have gone up a lot. And a lot of these stories
that were written in twenty thirteen, twenty,
fourteen, twenty fifteen, they don't look as
true now because using the same data I have, if
you go and stop the story in twenty thirteen, it
looks pretty dire for millennials. I'm not
going to lie, but you move four to five
years. It's like, oh things have caught up,
you know, things are starting to happen and
it isn't looking as bad now. And so that's kind
of the thing I see. So in terms of home ownership,
yeah, there's a lot of issues there. And obviously
prices have gone up, but rates are lower. So like
the the cost of a mortgage may not necessarily be
that much higher or similar, but it's a complex
topic. There's a lot of issues to unpack there.
Speaker 1: So big picture. I mean, what what is
the kind of defining narrative overall about
how we should understand the financial picture
of millennials in the aggregate understanding, as
you say, that people people's personal experience
is their lived experience and that that's sort
of what it's going to feel like at the individual
level, at the aggregate is is there not much of
a story in terms of how millennials are doing
relative to prior generations financially?
Speaker 4: I don't I don't think I think it
depends. When you look as I said, if you go back
a couple of years, it looks pretty bad. But now
things of, you know, incomes have gone up a bit,
like assets have gone up as a result. Because of
that, millennials aren't looking as they don't
look like they're struggling as much. However,
I think the real story to take away here is there
is a subset of millennials that is struggling and
I think they need help. And so whether that's
right now, the there's debates about whether we
should cancel student loan debt or. Right.
We should have. Why not have a tax credit?
Every American gets a ten thousand dollar tax
credit that you can use towards education.
If you never use it, you lose it. If you've used
it in the past, you can use in the future. If you
paid off student loan debt ten years ago, guess
what? You can use it. You can write it off that.
I don't know exactly how that would work, but
something like that, where it's going to feel
fair, everyone gets it technically and it would
help those people that are in debt at least
somewhat. So I don't know if that's the solution,
but I think there are people that need help
and painting the picture of all
millennials are struggling. I think
that makes boomers look at millennials say,
oh, they're just lazy versus like, no, just
some millennials are struggling. Then boomers may
look at this and say, oh, that's the real problem,
we should help them. I think it's it's much easier
to help a subset of people than to be like, oh,
I'm not just going to do a massive wealth transfer
to millennials, which I don't think we need. I
think it's like any sort of thing like that. I
think it needs to be very targeted to the people
who are actually, like, in a really bad position.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, that's one of the
criticisms, one of the criticisms that comes
up about the just the blanket cancelation
of student debt is that it wouldn't really be
that progressive. And I'm not saying politically
progressive. I'm saying in terms of who it's who
it's hitting because there are lots of people
who have chosen to take on debt, even though
even though their financial position today
is actually quite good and you're going to be
hitting them even though their ability to repay
is actually significant, is that a fair criticism
of like a blanket student debt cancelation versus
something like what you're talking about?
Speaker 4: Yes, I see. The issue is like,
OK, personal responsibility. All I chose not
to go. And you have to realize, like what is
only a third of Americans end up getting a college
degree anyways. And so, like for me, I'm obviously
in a bubble where, like, most of my friends are
college educated. So like to me it's like, oh,
everyone has a college degree. But remember, it's
only about a third of Americans creating a policy
only for a third of Americans is something that
like and it's not like Age-Based or something like
Social Security. It's it's something that's going
to be hard to pass. That's why I'm saying, like,
try and come up with something that's like fair.
Maybe you come up with a policy where you can use
your these credits for a technical school, you can
use it for anything, you can use it for a coding
boot camp. You know, if you expand it to not
just be college debt, I think you can get a lot
more Americans in on it and it would actually help
people. So I think you need to just rethink that.
And that's also one of the reasons why I like
canceling student loan debt. Well, that's that
would be helpful to some people I. A lot of people
will see that and say, like, yeah, that's I why
am I paying for someone else's thing? So I think
you need to kind of make it a little bit more fair
to get a lot more Buy-In from from everyone.
I don't know how to do that. But yeah, this is
Speaker 1: the Andrew Yang idea was to include
trade school. And that's not unique to Andrew
Yang, just his name comes to mind. I know Joe
Biden has talked about that as well, and so have
others. I mean, I think the cultural issue around
the candidates, you've got the economic issue
where there are some on the American political
right who say, well, it just shouldn't be done
because either we can't afford it or people
haven't earned that cancelation because they
chose to go to school. They knew what it cost,
etc.. There's also the political cultural side of
the perception that college is left wing
indoctrination. And so there's some resistance
to that because there are people who politically
on the right think, well, if you encourage more
people to go to college, that's actually going
to be a problem politically. And that's probably
another hurdle that would have to be cleared.
Speaker 4: Of course, both of those things. I
think the fiscal arguments make more sense than
the indoctrination arguments. Obviously, yes,
the universities are more liberal for a host of
reasons, but I don't think it necessarily is being
indoctrination. I don't think it needs to be that
strong now. But I do think the fiscal arguments
you can make those like, yeah, can we afford
this, this and that? I think there are probably
some multiplier effect. I haven't really read
all the studies on this, but I think education
is generally good because if you go to do with
the joke is underwater basket weaving, you know,
that's probably not a good use of resources, but
I think a lot of a lot of educational things are,
I think, generally positive for society.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, I think when you look at
the range of the how stimulative different types
of government spending is, are, I don't know,
grammatically with the right word is there. On
the one hand, you've got like letting rich people
who have all of their expenses covered
just put more money in the bank account.
Right. That that would be on the low end. On the
other side, things like food stamps are extremely
stimulative in terms of a multiplier effect. And
we can imagine why the money is going right back
into local businesses. And it's increasing.
It's a demand side stimulus in communities.
I think education tends to be closer to the
food stamps side than the letting rich people
sock money away in a savings account side.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I would tend to probably
agree with that. I mean, I haven't looked
at the studies on it, but yeah, I mean,
I think education is probably closer to that than
something that's not really helpful.
Speaker 1: Nick, while while we have you here,
because you've written and tweeted a lot
about your ups and downs with cryptocurrency,
and if I recall correctly, a few
months ago, you got out, right?
Speaker 4: I got half out.
Speaker 1: You got half out. How about
what is your sense now of what we're seeing? I
recently did an interview with the CEO of Celsius,
who obviously has a vested financial interest in
saying this is only the beginning. This is going
to be great as someone who is half out and you
sort of have a casual interest in it would be cool
if that went up what you still have, but. But it
might not. What's your sense of what it's looking
like? The role of cryptocurrency is going to be
in the bigger financial picture going forward?
Speaker 4: I have no idea there that question. If
I knew if we knew the prices would reflect that,
whether that's up or down, if we knew it's not
going to be that useful. Like there's still a
lot of people saying, I don't see how a lot of the
stuff is useful or some people saying, oh, well,
this is going to take over the world. Everyone's
using Bitcoin for everything. I think the truth
is somewhere between the two, I don't think it's
the most useful thing ever and I don't think it's
absolutely useless either. And the reason I sold
wasn't because I have some sort of market outlook.
I was just like I bought it with a it was supposed
to be a certain percentage of my portfolio.
It grew. I got it. Eight thousand. It was
up at fifty two when I sold half of it and
I paired that half off to get back to a fair
allocation of what I feel comfortable with.
I can't have I mean it kept growing. It just and
that's what happens. It got too big. And I sense
now that the prices have come down. I said, OK,
well the allocations got smaller. I'm also looking
at I looked at a theory. I'm a little bit I maybe
I'll get some of that. So now I have a little
bit of a theory, reallocation and stuff. My half
bitcoin just because yeah. If prices drop enough,
I will buy more cryptocurrency to kind of keep my
allocation. And it's a very small allocation, but
it's something that I believe in. I run some
data on it and we'll see, we'll see what happens.
Obviously, no one knows the future.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Yeah. I mean,
that sounds similar to my position. I
mean, I think at more than ten years in,
there's no reason for me to think this is
going away. And even as different governments
have done have changed policy in different
ways, it's still not going away. And the
number of individuals holding at least
some seems to have gone up. So for me,
and this is not financial advice, I've said it's
like a three to four percent type of thing in
terms of in terms of asset allocation.
Speaker 4: Yeah, that's exactly kind of
the way I've kind of looked at it. It's like find
a small percentage. I remember if I'm we're not
here to give full financial advice, of course, but
the bulk of my investments are an income producing
assets are going to be like stocks, bonds,
real estate, stuff like that. So the bulk of my
wealth is in there and that's what I recommend for
people. What percentage? That's kind of up to you,
what you feel comfortable with. But yeah. So I
don't know what's happening crypto. But if it is a
revolution, if it is a revolutionary thing,
it's going to change the world. This is kind of
what you should expect with prices. Like it's
not just going to also I'll wake up tomorrow,
OK? We're all going to agree that this is the
price. No, it's going to go up way past that
price. It's going to crash below. It's going to
oscillate upwards until it finds its its final
price. And maybe it's too high relative to where.
It's equilibrium should be maybe it's too low if
it's like a digital gold, it's far too low right
now. If it's not a digital gold, it's maybe two,
I don't know. Right. So that's that's the truth.
Speaker 1: We have been speaking with Nick
Majilis, who runs the blog of Dollars and Data.
Now, here is my request to people in my audience.
If you disagree with what Nick says, tell him
where his data is wrong. No ad hominem, please.
Speaker 4: Yeah. Don't attack my back.
Speaker 1: Exactly. Exactly. Nix also
S.O.S results wealth management. Nick,
always great to talk to you.
Speaker 4: Great to talk to you as well, David.